foreign
[Music]
fellas
fellas how we doing welcome to another
Channel live stream is everyone excited
[Music]
I'm like a little bit scared because I
was testing out the stream and like it
just started dropping frames and that
was like I don't know what happened like
it was just like out it was just like
just basically stop streaming I had to
restart OBS so I don't know what's gonna
happen but
hopefully it'll work because I kind of
wanted to stream obviously that was the
plan because a lot of dare a game Jam is
like next weekend
not this coming weekend but one after
which is like pretty wild
because
like
I just remember it being like 50 days
away 40 days away now it's 10 days away
and like the time just flies and there's
still quite a bit of stuff I wanted to
do before like that begins
um so
yeah so how you guys are doing morning
from the UK good morning to you first
YouTube stream ever now I did I did one
like I used to stream on YouTube like 10
years ago then I kind of stopped
switched to Twitch uh but then like a
few weeks ago I did a YouTube live
stream so this is like my second one in
modern times we'll see music is a bit
yeah is it really that loud the music I
can turn it down a bit
I don't know
hopefully be all right I'll tell them
that the mic up as well a little bit
um Okay so
yeah basically what I want to do is
um today what we're going to do is we're
going to take a look at some basically
kind of like it was similar to what we
were doing last time I think on the last
YouTube live stream
uh
let me just um I'm gonna tweet this out
forgot to do that
typical
let's do this real quick you guys just
entertain yourselves
all right all right class I'm back
what's the plan for the stream today
yeah um so uh we're gonna be working on
like some Hazel stuff let me just uh
switch this
um so yeah like there's still quite a
bit of work that I have to do
um there's part of this like new
renderer kind of rewrite situation and
so we're going to continue on with that
let me just launch this like see where
we're at in general but we're gonna just
basically continue it's just this is
just going to be a programming live
stream we're just going to write some
code and make stuff like this hopefully
work why is this crashing why is this
not working already
um what are we even running
has the run time okay well that needs a
Shader pack
and I guess it doesn't have one or it's
not built or something
is going on here I'm trying to run
dichotomy that's probably the not the
right one uh this is on my other account
this is gonna be a mess
um I might have to like
steals these some stuff from my desktop
of my other account
yeah like this and this is kind of what
I wanted to do
let's just pop it like here
and I think I don't know if that'll work
but it's supposed to be this one
anyway yeah I think I know why so let's
set the working directory there and
we'll take a look and yeah we're just
gonna chill out like this is like we're
gonna have a good time chill out I'll
try and like be active with Chad as well
um and see what's going on as I work
here what I'm gonna be reasonably like I
want to actually try and get some work
done as well
um all right let's just debug this I
don't know why this is not working I'm
pretty sure it should be okay what's up
um let's see where's my chat at any
plans to continue Ray tracing series yes
uh I just haven't had time honestly like
I just haven't had time to sit down
prepare the episodes so
um yeah
[Music]
so
um
where uh
um I'm gonna get back to that probably
after like a lot of death after the game
Jam because I've been kind of preparing
it's kind of like you know I've got a
bunch of videos coming up that aren't
Ray tracing related and then so I've
been busy with kind of working on videos
but then there's also like preparing
Hazel obviously for letting them
finishing up my new like huge like
renderer rewrite thing as well so
there's been a lot of like programming
work and stuff to actually do
there's a puzzle to create new Shadows
inside Hazel um not like inside inside
Hazel meaning like because then using
like the editor like you have to
actually like you'll have to write some
C plus code but yeah like it's pretty
easy like I I've basically on all of the
we've used Hazel twice for two different
game jams as a team we've used the
forest which was like a year ago and
then like six months ago was like
dichotomy and I added like custom render
passes and shaders for certain Graphics
like graphical effects to both those
games it was like a fog effect in forest
and then dichotomy had like an outline
Shader
um so I did that during the game jam and
it was like pretty simple
so yeah it's definitely possible all
right why can't you load anything man
why is it trying to load no well that
should be inside the Shader pack
I don't know why like I swear I left
this this was working last time I don't
even remember like what what did I do
so it obviously can't load the Shader
um
like as in this Shader pack which it
should be looking at this path let's
take a look at what this looks like
because it should just be resources oh
it's not here
what
but this is oh because it's in dichotomy
resources
right so this should be the working
directory I think that's why
what's your take on table plus 23 I
haven't
um like I don't know any I don't can't
name a single feature from the from
there I just haven't
been in on that why why is it this one
that I can't load again
uh
so this I guess is null and it's now
what is this the path yes the pre
integration Shader is it because it's a
lowercase s
I don't think so oh maybe it is let's
try uppercase s because it um hashes the
string for Shredder packs so that might
be why
foreign
yeah it is I mean this is like a
different problem I think what I don't
understand is that this is the
ah this is the wrong Branch man can you
believe that I've just been working off
the wrong I opened the wrong Hazel
it's
um because the right one's not here for
some reason oh because I didn't really
haven't streamed the right one yet so
it's not in my recent on this user
account so it's called Dev final I think
okay sorry I was in the wrong solution
what a joke
[Music]
am I Russian uh yes kind of I'm like
half I was born in Australia I'm half
Russian half moldovian because my my
dad's rushing my mom's gonna drive in
um but yeah I guess I was born in
Australia so I'm also Australian
uh uh can I also speak German yes a
little bit
and vision
because I went to school there for a
while when I was little
because my parents kind of wanted to
move there you're planning to make uh
Hazel ship games to consoles if yes then
how would we host proprietary code for
console that's the case I haven't really
thought that far
um like as in how we're gonna host the
proprietary code like we'll just have it
like I guess it'll be locked down a
little bit more and you might have to
sign a license agreement kind of like
Godot does it
um but yes like I would like to support
consoles in the future but that will
probably only happen after we actually
ship up an actual premium kind of title
uh using Hazel which is in the works
like we're planning to do that obviously
that's why we're kind of making like a
game engine as well like because like
it's not just like so that you guys can
like you know well okay there's a few
reasons like obviously because I love
game engines and I want to make a game
engine but also like to kind of teach
you guys I guess and give you something
to play with as well which is good uh
but then like the other big reason is we
just want to make games and we're going
to do it in our own engine so that's
like another big reason
what's your opinion on templates uh
templates are good
um but if you go too wild with them they
are bad
they're good in moderation like like
most things in life
do you like kotlin haven't really tried
it much that's like the Java kind of
successor thing isn't it that like
Android apps are written in these days
[Music]
have you experienced frame times with
Vulcan one balanced power plant is
action have not tried that
no matter how powerful PCS or how much
random times I've spent yeah well that's
just typically how Windows kind of
computers and hardware and stuff works
like even even like lots of laptops need
um
you know they need the uh the AC adapter
plugged in because
because they um
uh they need the extra wattage that the
battery can't even supply for the gpus
so it's yeah I mean
that's kind of like it's to be expected
that you'd get starters and stuff if
you're not probably on full on full
speed on full performance
Global illumination plan for hazel
what's your isolation you're planning to
implement um yeah we basically have that
already like in a branch I had made it
work I don't think I've pushed it though
to GitHub so I don't get too excited um
but yeah it's just rtxgi is probably
what we'll use it works really really
well and
um
uh even and and it can be used really
easily even if you don't have an RTX GPU
because you can just make those kind of
light Maps so it's not as Dynamic
obviously but you can kind of get it to
run the ray tracing shaders on compute
obviously and then just it'll be slower
but it can be okay
so that's kind of what we're doing it's
just that like I haven't been I actually
I added that about six months ago but I
stopped there because we decided like we
were initially going to make a game
we were initially going to make a game
that like uh used like you know Global
illumination and light map baking and
all that stuff so I kind of was kind of
working on that Tech but then we decided
to go a different direction completely
and so the game kind of that we're like
working on in in pre-production I guess
now uh that doesn't have like that's not
going to need that Tech so nobody's
gonna need a different Tech so
[Music]
um
that's why like I I stopped working on
that and started working on stuff
all right this is becoming a q a
live stream
all right what are you guys talking
about you guys talking about who the
heck I am right
um Anya's Ukrainian yes she is she was
born in Kiev
your moldovian uh I can't speak Romanian
no I was brought up speaking Russian
just like Anya as well
[Music]
are you utilizing new AI tools for
workload of code not really outside of
just for fun so like I've asked chat GPT
to do some stuff just for fun but I
haven't really I don't really use it as
part of my work no probably should start
maybe to just ask her for help sometimes
but yeah
as a YouTube only stream yes
or on YouTube so it is usually only I
guess q a stream would be cool though
yeah maybe maybe someday
um the reason why I'm not really uh
doing that now or why this isn't become
a q a stream is because I got a lot of
work to do so let's get back to the work
so um this should be the right thing
especially because I what's going on yep
I'm doing wonderfully
um yeah especially because I wasted the
first like part of this whole session
just doing absolutely nothing because
um
because
uh I opened up the wrong solution I
opened up a different branch all right
so this is dichotomy
um on
the new in the new engine like in the
new kind of renderer
right so that's pretty good
um now
uh what one of the things I actually
wanted to do uh there's a couple things
that we need to do like first of all I'm
kind of working to clean this up if we
just open up Fork real quick
this is like the game engine series but
let me just open this guy
[Music]
okay so for those of you playing along
at home who do have access on
patreon.com
and you do have access to Hazel then
this is located in
the
uh rentra 2023 Branch so that's the
branch that I'm working on at the moment
and
uh I'm basically cleaning it up so you
can see I'm going through like all this
code here and I'm just removing like a
lot of it uh because this was like the
old system I explained I think at some
point the way that I wrote This was
um
like I kind of implemented like the new
renderer kind of along with the old
renderer so I don't really get rid of
like a lot of the you know the way that
we handled materials and stuff and if
you have no idea what I'm talking about
this is by the way this is like I put
out a video last night just on my
YouTube channel so my latest video on my
YouTube channel is like about what the
heck's going on so watch that video if
you have no idea what I'm working on
because I'm still kind of working on
this
okay so
um
yeah okay so there's some stuff that I
wanna kind of iron out I think now from
memory there was a problem with
there was an actual issue that I had
with shade and macros like this guy here
that's why I ended up setting some of
these to true and like it was just not
ideal
um but
[Music]
other than that I'm just going through
and cleaning up a whole bunch of stuff
and then I'll probably commit that
because like a lot of this stuff isn't
news like I don't think this is used
anymore
yeah it's it's not right and that's
probably not used so this can just go
away
I think that thread pull is even used
that was just a little experiment at
some point let me just compile this make
sure I didn't remove anything I need
[__]
[Music]
all right
um
yeah that was like this example of how
random passes should work
so this was like I don't know if I
should leave any of this in here
probably not
I don't know why I did this little
pragma region thing probably not going
to do that
and then there's like yeah this stuff is
all oh you know what I wanted to do this
is what I wanted to do I basically
wanted to rewrite this stuff so that it
wasn't
so basically those of you like following
along with this journey you know that um
one of the things that we got rid of is
basically descriptor sets used to be
allocated every frame and then updated
every frame uh kind of like as they're
as needed and then the whole pool gets
reset once per frame so that's how we
used to do things
uh now we don't do that anymore but a
certain certain things such as Bloom
compute over here
uh and like I think the pre-integration
pass as well which I didn't write that
career at that but
um this the this kind of stuff still
does actually
use that system so materials don't and
like the main renderer doesn't but
certain compute passes still do and that
should be removed so basically you can
see like where the descriptor set here
comes from Falcon renderer rtlk
descriptor set so this basically like
shouldn't really happen anymore I think
that function is still useful although
maybe not because it uses just like a
global descriptive pool which we
probably shouldn't use anymore
um let me switch to debug
let's just quickly see who uses this I'm
gonna stick a break point here and just
run it I want to see who uses this
function I think it's going to be I mean
I could just do final references but
it's less fun
[Music]
I mean shaders for some reason do that
but I I don't know if that's actually
used that might be also old code
because this really shouldn't this just
okay this is just like a utility
function that allocates a uh descriptor
set for you in like the layout that you
want so that's really all it is and the
layout itself is from a specific set
inside the Shader
so it's kind of why
um
[Music]
yeah so that's so this is coming from
age that we compute so yeah so you can
see this for example does it as well so
hzb does it let me just probably keep
some notes
so we'll we'll go over because we're
gonna probably strip all of this out now
but it's going to be a bit of a
challenge so hzv compute
uses it then there's a few times
pre-integration I can see up here so
here it is as well
um I'm just looking at the call stack by
the way if you have no idea no idea what
I'm doing
this is still going how many do we
allocate here oh it's because it's going
through all the maps isn't it yep all
right
pre-convolution compute as well
[Music]
lots of times for all the maps
so that's quite a quite a fat stack of
stuff finally got a little validation
error
why why is this still happening uh
it's again it's to do with those macros
being weird that's that's what it is
because you can see there's a dispatch
and it's probably
um
maybe SSR is probably the compute
pipeline
I was having some trouble with that
[Music]
is this which one is this
yes it is
effects
SSR that's giving us that issue
um to look at all that because I know I
know I know I know all about that
uh Bloom yeah Bloom we knew
okay that's cool that's cool lots of
Bloom lots of Bloom everywhere
for all the maps for down sampling and
up sampling and everything it requires
you to allocate a descriptor set which I
don't want to do another validation
error
what's this one
[Music]
that's the same as layout issue that's
easy
did I fix that one though odd
uh and then that's actually H said to be
compute all right so the solution
basically
[Music]
is like what I want to do
yeah I'm enjoying the music the music is
um
what is the music the music is uh well
just epidemic sound like just yeah Jazz
that's it
love me some jazz when it's yeah
[Music]
all right
um
so uh yeah so so basically if we look at
Bloom I'll start with Bloom because I
wrote that so I'm a bit more comfortable
in this area
[Music]
um if we go through the bloom the bloom
uh the reason why we end up doing this
manually in Vulcan is because we need
to basically obtain uh
like
an image where is this gonna be
[Music]
we need to specifically like
get I think an image view I mean what's
this used for maps so where's where's
this used yeah so you can see like we
specifically need an image view to be
bound to one of the mips so this is like
image one and then MIP image view for
that specific myth
and that's why because
um the way the balloon works is as you
kind of go down you know the chain and
you down sample it will basically read
like the previous map and write it to
the next map
and so on and so forth and then up
sampling does the same but kind of in
reverse and like to a different texture
I think or maybe not maybe it reuses the
same texture but anyway
um
so
that and and the problem is that we
don't have a way in Hazel at the moment
to represent essentially an image view
so we can just have an image right so we
create an image for this if we go up
here you can see we have Bloom textures
I don't know why that textures are not
images but whatever
um we have these Bloom textures which
get passed in here and Bloom textures
which are created over here that
attached 2DS but the problem is uh what
we need is we essentially need
um like it's fine that we create these
textures and you can see it generates oh
and that's why they're textures because
when you generate maps and I don't think
we support that for images per se
whatever anyway the point is we create
these textures but
what we really kind of want to do like
they that contains the full map chain
but then we need a way to address
specific mips so we need to kind of
reduce the granularity of this so that
it's not just like we can't just tell
material here is the texture uh it would
be better for us to basically
um you know have I guess a texture sorry
have a material that needs to take in an
input but that input cannot just be like
it it doesn't just have to be an entire
texture or image it can be a specific
like sub kind of area of that in the
form of like at one of the myths so
that's what we kind of need to create
um now my idea for how we would do this
is probably like we can just ask for we
can just create this new thing called an
image view so we have like an image 2D
maybe we should have an image view 2D
and an image view to 2D can probably
just be
like basically we'd we'd kind of
um
do something like spec Dot
this would be its own thing obviously
uh it would be like
um well we'd pass in an image right so
the image would be like one of these
guys which I think we can get the image
from that
um and then uh but what would we do that
I guess because in this case the image
would contain all the mips and then we
can be like what miplap what like MIP
would you like
and then you could be like I want map
too and so this just like and there
could be some other things that we do
potentially like if it's a layer layered
image because you can have like a
texture array then maybe you want to
create a view of a specific slice of
that as well
[Music]
um so like that's also something that it
could handle but for now and like for a
cube map it could be like one specific
face of it if you wanted like there's a
lot of things that this this could do so
it's not just gonna be like for MEPS but
it could be in the beginning
um and yeah like api-wise again we
obviously already support the
functionality because Bloom's working
fine
it's just it's a bit awkward from an API
point of view because Hazel's API
doesn't quite support that and so you
kind of have to do a bit of
uh you know a little bit of maneuvering
I guess to get that to work and you can
see we even have like you know for
example RT get me up image view which
you can ask an image 2D to give you a
MIB and it caches it as well
per
um
you know per view
we'll probably make this a bit faster as
well by um
[Music]
doing this
um but yeah so you can see that will
give you a view what per level like so
you only get one level one map and this
is the index of the map so we already
have all this and this just creates an
image view basically so we just need to
kind of wrap that in an object that we
can then provide to a render pass or a
compute pass or a material
and I don't know exactly how we'll set
it up but at least it will not require
us to manually allocate a descriptor
because I guess what we would do like
I'm guessing it sounds a bit wasteful
but I feel like the the way that you
would make that work is
you'd probably want to set up a material
per pass
right you'd have a material per pass
and so if your bloom had like you know
eight down sample passes or whatever and
eight up sample passes you'd basically
create
16 materials but the benefit
is that those 16 materials
would already have like all of the
descriptor sets ready to go and so you
would just bind the one you need and you
just go
but obviously if you don't do that like
obviously if you're doing what we're
doing you're actually setting it up now
surprisingly I'm pretty sure this is
fairly fast like I don't think this is
that slow
all right it's hard to no it's all it's
all inside this isn't it
we could easily like if I just go
Um
how do I add a timer to this
to present or something or
not because that's something that has
yeah this
if I just put a little one of these guys
in here I'll just call this bloom
Bloom compute
I'll do it I'll name it RT blue and
compute if we just go back up to here
and
get rid of that if I just go back to the
run time
pretty sure I'm showing that but
I'm sure I am
where at the time is that here they are
well it's false all right so we should
see them now
and that's gonna obviously tell us the
CPU time for that scope
on the round of thread
um oh it's this garbage you can't see
this is like it's weird the way that it
compiles these
shaders
that will work properly no it won't
yeah this is this is an unrelated issue
unfortunately that happens
sometimes
does it just happen I should have done
release anyway does this just happened
in debug now this will happen in release
as well
what time is it for me it's like 7 15.
P.M
okay so this is upset because probably
because of oh no this can't be because
of that I think it's because oh actually
yeah why is that upset
uh what does the log say nothing
beautiful let's um do that again and
we'll see
we'll see why that failed
[Music]
I throw
a throw wait is it not it should be
logging I think it's oh here it is no
that's the verifying okay
[Music]
I might have disabled logging for that
tag as well in the project settings
foreign
yeah so this is the problem
um
but I'm in release what am I doing
we might have to fix this issue before
we progress
because it's a bit annoying
[Music]
okay so what is this this is the bloom
dirt textile
and I guess it's it's now
and it's not an image today it's a
texture to the ah
who cares I think
but why is that only failing now
suddenly
Bloom dirt texture oh it's because I I
commented it out what
okay never mind that's that's actually
valid
[Music]
okay what's your problem
ah there this
wait what
did I break this
[Music]
ah because in that case it has two
okay let me change this oh whoa what the
heck is this thing
whoa I did not know that was a thing
so that's I think that's
uh that's for like JavaScript probably
that's basically this and this all of
these drawn together that's funny
let's change this so that we just do
that
I kind of broke that accidentally and
otherwise we'll create it
uh we'll create it and then we'll have
to return it so this actually gets put
in though doesn't it
yeah so there it is okay image map views
and then we're returning it
I'll just do that whatever
as long as like we're optimizing the
fast path which is this kind of path up
here
um then that's fine
[Music]
a sleepy just wanted to say before I go
sleep nice that's relevant
um
found your channel through receiver plus
videos and those are helping me out so
much thank you so much now good night
everyone thank you for
thank you for me thanking you I mean
thank you for thanking me helping you
you're welcome
um all right what's wrong with you
[Music]
ah this was I guess we should probably
see what's up with this shouldn't we
said this is like the what is this
which which one is this
so annoying
once
[Music]
so wrong the script from writing seven
index zero yeah well binding seven
requires
you end component type of boundaries
format is this
okay
how did that go wrong
which pipeline is this
SSR again it's a saw SSR is like I don't
know what's going on with that Shader
but I feel like because we're like the
Mac something macro is weird about it
and it's like as in there are some
Shader macros we're using but the shade
of macro system is weird I think so
it's uh compiling possibly without
certain code enabled or disabled and the
runtime is not sure what it compiled
with and if because you can basically
there are some optional textures you can
provide
for that now
um what am I saying render right here it
is
now
so yeah so this guy basically
um is optional kind of I think
[Music]
and like it's because it's behind this
macro
so it's a little bit weird
I don't know I don't quite know what to
do
with that but what seems to be let's
maybe look at the message again what
seems to be the problem is
it like and the thing is it says binding
seven which is this guy here right we
know it's this guy because this guy's
the only they're always causing a
problem but the thing is we're not we
haven't even set anything into that slot
and this should be disabled right
um
I mean
I mean I think I yeah I did this here
oh but no but get AO method GTA enabled
is true so AO method would be
true then actually because this is based
on oh but this is a reflection occlusion
method this is this guy so this is
actually yeah and see it's set to none
right so if we set this To None because
I put oh that's insane renderer
oh maybe that's why
well no because I've set it to zero
so a reflection
occlusion method should be zero which
means that this should obviously
be false so that shouldn't be included
in the Shader
but I think it is somehow and that's the
weird thing
um
so it's a bit unfortunate because yeah I
need to figure out a better solution to
that probably
um
but for now I don't know like if we
bring this back but it's going to be the
wrong side I don't know if it's even
it's up here
let's see what happens this will
probably work but it's a bit sus
[Music]
or is that the same error
no so that's the way that's the let's
also fix this one
so this is happening because
[Music]
um basically something is attempting to
use yeah I thought I fixed this man did
I not fix this
[Music]
so there should be a clear pass that
does that yeah look it's here
oh but we potentially need Shadow passes
no but no that doesn't make sense either
because this is different actually this
is so this is um
but what expects this
I like this music
uh so the shadow Cascades texture
uh is supposed to be basically it hasn't
been written too
stop
so we haven't actually rendered anything
to it I'm gonna turn a sample from it
[Music]
it's definitely this guy so what that
means is somehow we wound up inside a
geometry pass without having
gone through it or maybe it's oh no no I
know what it is I
I think it's because I reduce the
Cascades to one for dichotomy
but I may not have actually done that
[Music]
doesn't have anything
no we don't use Dynamic rendering
[Music]
yeah see it's array layer one
so that that must mean that it's still
actually creating four of them
but I should I don't think it should be
oh yes it is okay
so this is different
this
should be this
that's why because we always used to
have four Cascades but now we can
customize it
because dichotomy only needs one Cascade
um and this is coming from where
this also might be from uh
from thingy
yes so it's supposed to do this
yeah
but hang on what was it used for
existing image
let's just do this
see if that works
[Music]
yeah a lot of dare is like next weekend
all right my session failed which one
why did that not break then
is this dead it's going on ah here it is
it's about to break all right so get
Leia this didn't work either
oh because we have an existing image
I guess the problem is that like we
probably really want it to be an array
in fact it's even taken it as a sample
studio right but it's only got one
one thing in it so that's a bit sus
so it kind of needs to be I guess one
yeah
uh okay so
[Music]
why is this here though depth attachment
as well why is that that's irrelevant I
don't think I added that code
foreign
yeah like I don't know I feel like ah I
should have just skipped that but I feel
like that's fine
because we're not using it for the
Korean probably out of that
that little lassette
okay and then something uh here is all
right because that's not gonna work
potentially
but
oh that's size zero
well yeah I guess because it doesn't
have it
but the reason why so why is this where
are we why is that trying to do that oh
image yeah so get layer image view why
what a work we must be in a weird
section where are we in the code
it was just invalidate
oh because layers is greater than one
get specification layers so we must have
also
my layers is one all right
what
yeah so it does
yeah okay so that actually this is just
this is just a bit of a blunder so
um
it's really only allowed to do this if
that's true otherwise it should do that
so I mean we can put that a set back
let's try that
all right
laughs
image viewers now
okay that's not great
so I'm guessing this is the shadow pass
no this is a geometry pass okay
it's the geometry past but I'm guessing
that
[Music]
um
I'm guessing that
so if we take a look at
the geometry path which is here
it's going to take it's going to have to
take in unless the pipeline
which I'll have to clean up later it's
gonna basically it's gonna have to take
in
um yeah this
so why is that
wrong then because that shouldn't be
let's let's take a look at this I guess
that's null or something
foreign
but I guess the image view was now
ah I think I might know why
[Music]
no actually we didn't invalidate it so
what did this do this just created yeah
I mean it just created this per layer
image views
but we're not trying to use that
necessarily are we
[Music]
no
so I mean that kind of seems valid to me
I guess we can also also just look at
inside this image we can take a look
inside and see
if it has
yeah so it doesn't have an image view so
it didn't actually create this
for some reason
even though it looks like it kind of
should have
or did it oh did it just cue it up
because I think
yeah and validate does It On the Run
thread that's why so that's fine because
it should be there later
but I guess what that's telling us is
that it's not there later
[Music]
because it's it's saying that
image view must not be null handle why
is it not telling me which one but I
guess we can look at these write
descriptions to update so one of these
is null
[Music]
so combine image sample and you can see
image amp image info is null
so that's what it is index two
that's valid
but why why doesn't it have
so I guess we can go back to image and
look at how to invalidate because
clearly it didn't actually
it didn't actually create the image view
or anything
which is odd because it kind of looks
like it it definitely should have I
don't see how it wouldn't have
it's very strange isn't it
hmm
like why would it not have
okay so let's see invalidated input
resources that was probably the oh
they're all day yeah
this guide
this guy doesn't have anything
so directional Shadow map depth
attachment zero yeah has no
it doesn't exist
how
it's got a GP allocation size or does it
is that that seems way too big
hmm
it's kind of weird
[Music]
that's so weird I don't know why I
didn't create my image
laughs
[Music]
foreign
actually hang on it might be a different
one
because we uh yeah I mean that would
make sense
it might be this weird or stuff that
I've done here
but it shouldn't be because it's depth
attachment image as Vulcan so he's uh
if existing
so
yeah so it tries to do that truck but if
existing image which is true then
oh this is
but it does
images depth attachment image so that
should have gotten sad
earlier
yeah into existing image right
because what I'm worried about is it may
have created an image maybe but I don't
think it did
like they could be there could be two
images basically accidentally
[Music]
what have we set it to because the thing
is like if we create a frame buffer with
existing image set to something which we
did here
then it basically just says depth
attachment if it's a depth format two
existing image and that's it
and it doesn't call invalidate on it
because it's an existing image and it
should have already happened and yeah
and we're in our team validator so that
this should be after the initial image
was already created so basically by the
time we get here
um
we should like the depth attachment
image will be an existing image
um and so two attachments we in place
the image view from that image
[Music]
so that should be there
right
and then when we ask for
that image later
[Music]
get output
then we basically will yeah we'll do
this
get depth image
and that just Returns the definition
this is very very strange
what's the difference between a certain
verify assert is debug
like as in it will be triggered in debug
gun release
sorry it'll be triggered in debug only
but verify is both debug and release
configurations
but not distribution
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
it's so weird that this has happened I
mean we can take a look the problem is
[Music]
the problem is it's kind of hard to
what if it's because of the usages I
don't think so though
[Music]
oh that should be fine
yeah that's really weird
said that a bunch but I honestly don't
know why
I don't know I don't know why that image
is not
because I'm pretty sure we created it
but it's not
actually how are you storing this what
if we are just being weird about how
we're throwing it I don't think we are
though
because we're not exactly storing you
we're actually retrieving it from the
image right here
relaxes violation
now
probably shouldn't let it get to that
point but still so it's clearly
happening here right so okay how about
we do this
Edge set of four verify I will do image
info image
a few
so we'll just we'll let's verify that
that's so we're gonna hit this now
obviously but at least for Belgium maybe
debug but it's so weird
[Music]
it is the verify
because the image here is now so this is
the image right does it have a name do
we give it a name yeah directional
Shadow map depth attachment zero but is
that what we called it I feel like
that's a different image
because this didn't have a name this was
just called Shadow Cascades see
this image is called Shadow Cascades
but this image
is called directional Shadow map depth
attachment zero which only happens if it
gets created by the frame buffer so this
Frame buffer is creating its own image
it's not using this existing one and
that's why it's not working
which by the way like I mean it can do
that I'm still not sure why that image
happens to be null though because even
if it does create it its own image that
should be okay
right like
oh
it's because we don't actually create
the frame up here we then go here and we
do existing image layers in place back I
so that's why I guess existing image
layers is a thing
yeah so the thing is like
this should probably work very
differently if it's on if it just has
one Shadow map versus a whole bunch of
them
because like
[Music]
ah this just isn't necessary so but this
must be I don't know if it's worth
making this work
but does it matter that you have these
now
aha so it must not have I guess this is
kind of what happened
happens if that's not present but if it
is then it does this maybe and then that
was a that's a bit of a different path
[Music]
um
so let's and then we just create it yeah
so basically all that it's doing here is
it has it does have an existing image
layers specified
so what does that affect but it's only
used in these it's only here isn't it
ions here as well so this is this must
be what's happening
but isn't that what we just did
[Music]
I that shouldn't matter though it
doesn't look like it should matter
[Music]
this just means it refers to a
particular instance of that or a
particular layer I guess of that image
but if the image only has one layer
so that's just checking to make sure you
only have one here
because you can actually have a subset
but
you've set existing image though
but this this doesn't actually this just
affects the attachment that's sent to
Vulcan it doesn't it doesn't affect
um the other thing so
if existing frame buffer is full I guess
what we should do it honestly is let's
just step through it because it's
getting a little bit challenging to try
and read that all so this is where the
front buffer gets created now half of it
will kind of probably get sent to the
render thread maybe but
[Music]
we'll see what happens
so existing remember is false uh we have
one attachment so we're gonna go through
this
um
existing images true but this only
happens if the layers is greater than
one which is not so therefore we go to
finding this
uh existing images but existing images
isn't here because there's only one
existing image so actually it goes here
and it creates a new depth image okay
that's what happens so I don't actually
think layers has to be greater than one
here I don't know why that would be
there this code
let's just remove this
let's try that this might work
so this is why stepping through the card
is so much better I mean I talked about
this in a video recently
best way to read code or whatever but
um
yeah it's nice okay so okay that's
actually correct now that's just because
the Shader actually needs to be compiled
differently depending on like the vet
the variant here so
this is a bit annoying
um
because I don't know how we would do
this
because again as I said macros are
annoying so therefore
[Music]
all right
foreign
because basically like in our Shader
I don't even know where
this is declared
not here
see this is marked as a sampler 2D array
which it should be because we have
cascaded Shadow mapping but in dichotomy
for example where we don't have that
uh it needs to be a sampler 2D because
it's just one texture
I don't know if we could still trade it
as an array of size one
but probably not like we should
specifically have like a Cascade and
like it should know how much
but the thing is like you know if we did
something like if you know
[Music]
you know shake Shadow
Cascades or whatever
is we we could probably do something
like
this
but again that requires us to compile
the Shader differently which means that
you kind of have to set the setting you
either ship with two variants of the
Shader
because we don't compassionators at
runtime
um
so you either ship with two variants of
the Shader
uh compiled with different macros or you
or you what
oh no or you just ship with one variant
but then you have to choose in the
editor how many Cascades you want and
then that's seven Stone
foreign
so this is kind of what we'd have to do
I guess
could obviously do
if you were really cool you could
do something like this
[Music]
that looks a bit disgusting though
we could try that but the thing is the
runtime is going to have
[Music]
oh I don't know if I want to deal with
this now
because the run time like yeah
should probably make this work in the
editor first anyway
[Music]
um let's uh
I'll keep this but I'll put it back to
this
and like the thing is like I could
obviously just be like whatever you know
let's why does this not work
[Music]
ah GTA oh zero
what the heck is wrong with this though
it just won't create the compute
pipeline
the shadow not compile or
social strainers uh it's probably my is
it my
and my working directory said to that
it's trying to load this though
I should be using a Shader pack
so therefore that should have worked
yeah it's not
don't know why nothing's working today
[Music]
I'm going to release let me try a debug
Yeah so basically yeah I mean this
probably needs some decent design
because we don't really support this yet
exactly
[Music]
so I guess the compile didn't succeed
this has happened before
[Music]
yeah okay so this looks like these guys
don't have an alternation characters
[Music]
well actually no it's probably just the
logging
foreign
why is it upset with this though
oh no it is it's defined to zero with
that there
um
okay I think I know what that is
that's probably because I did this
and I guess that but that that's weird
isn't it
that's weird though this should provide
a
multimeter string Hill right
[Music]
what happens if I
do this
well that still cause the same issue
no that worked I think
or did it
I think it did but this set because
it's missing something now because
it does need some well actually this is
the compute pass
so let's see what the compute pass wants
to just turn on the log logging again
okay here we go so
what's this resource it's a uniform buff
on what
[Music]
what
this is missing an entire uniform buffer
how
these are valid
ah it's because it compiled it into a
different name
because that happens as well oh that's
so weird though why it does that I still
couldn't figure that out
ah
there's this weirdo thing that happens
sometimes guys or basically like
so you know I have
because this gtao Shader this GTA
computer is written in hlsl
even though like
we've named the uh
like the camera buffer so it includes
buffers.hlsl and then we have a we have
something called like camera here right
but sometimes and usually like it takes
it like it the reflection data will
actually have that name there but
occasionally what somehow happens I
don't know how
but what sometimes happens and that's
that's the problem is sometimes
I don't know why
um is it basically
um
it's
will
where is this in here
maybe it's not here uh input
declarations here we go yeah see it will
call it this
type.constantbuffer.camera instead of
just camera
and so the thing is though the weird
thing is sometimes it is just that
because when I first saw this I'm like
oh whatever I'll just change it to that
so it's happy because it just matches
the string right but then the next time
around it wasn't this
which is like ridiculous
why are they doing that
um I don't know let's I guess we can try
it again so what I'll do is I'll delete
the Shader cache
um and let's see what happens
oh and actually while I'm at it
let me maybe go into I guess here
where's the project file
and let's set the renderer to trade
maybe not Trace one
maybe info
traces way too traces like clock me
every round of pass as it happens best
[Music]
I was gonna compile everything
I guess it takes a while
maybe it will actually tell us what the
thing is why is it so slow man
look at this
it's crazy this looks slower than usual
what the heck
now it's going faster weird
[Music]
stairs gtao
yeah look see it's
typed.constantpuffer why
ah so that's not gonna work that's so
strange man
the fact that it sometimes happens oh
[Music]
does it depend on like the version of
the compiler
or something
[Music]
the version of the Shader compiler Maybe
okay so this isn't working
um
what causes this
[Music]
air composite
and I guess that doesn't have an input
that it wants or something
[Music]
yes this macro is being weird is what it
is
try that
see if I may see any difference
[Music]
times are tough sometimes
that's just the way it is
[Music]
far as well
man something weird is going on
what could it be
[Music]
see that's wrong again
it's because it it doesn't have an
alternation character
[Music]
why not
so what does it set it to
Global shade of macros it's a bunch of
strings
so where is this used
in the shadow compiler so here it is
global macros and we add macro
definition
which takes in a string and that string
of course is going to have an
alternation character
right
so add macro definition
is uh yeah obviously from
um
[Music]
that's yeah that's part of shade of C
foreign
[Music]
length but we're not using that version
I think we're using this version so it
should do name String name dot size
well yeah I mean it should be
I wonder why that's happening
that seems so weird
foreign
[Music]
so strange
foreign
[Music]
just having a think
about what this could be
foreign
[Music]
we support Linux thanks to Emily who's
in chat his IC as well hello
um so yeah Linux Hazel works on Linux
probably put up a video soon about that
maybe after let him down
maybe we can hopefully we can ship out a
lot of their game
on Linux as well
[Music]
that's so strange man
that's so strange
foreign
[Music]
T work though the size I mean the size
is one right like
what the heck
how are you not working
I mean uh actually that's pretty prices
jlsl where's pre-process hlsl maybe it's
different oh my gosh I think it is
different
oh
okay so here they are these Global
macros
all right
so it creates this thing called that ah
but it does plus one maybe it doesn't
initialize it to zero
I think I found the problem luckily
so here's our buffer uh-huh
um
and it does have it it's allocated looks
like oh and these are white wide charts
it's allocated with enough space for a
null
termination character but it doesn't
actually add it
so there it is
so that just probably worked by chance
before again I didn't write this code
so we need to make sure we put that in
is that right
so
validate that
[Music]
what's up Peter
Ah that's still a problem should I do
the wrong thing
wait why is it times two
[Music]
why is that times two
oh because they're wide charts
so that makes sense right
[Music]
yeah so that's fine yeah yeah because
this I'm guessing respects that
[Music]
therefore we copy that amount of White
characters which is no but these are
already wide characters so why is it
times two
because this is not we're not allocating
bytes here
so I think that looks like a bug to me
let's try that
[Music]
okay that's correct
all right
[Music]
still doesn't fix the weird naming
though
which means that this probably won't
work
yeah because this isn't called camera
it's called like stupid stupid
um why is it so annoying and didn't I
say like log why is it not logging
or am I opening something else here now
I'm opening I'll do 51.
[Music]
ah
all right
that's fine yeah
yeah so I set that why is that not
that's a warm it's not being printed
even though I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
set you to info your pile of garbage
so why are you not logging
[Music]
oh it's because it hasn't loaded the
protocol I think it probably has
[Music]
the whole filter is error
don't think so man
shouldn't be what tag is this
tag is render
how strange anyway
uh so it's
returned false because I already did
that
okay back you go
start again
whoa not that far
all right I give up
go away
do that again
yeah types uniform buffer and it's
because the name is different
different the name is this type dot
constant buffer garbage
why is this the case
[Music]
foreign
the the latest thing is that it's not
consistent though that's like the thing
that's really really weird about it
it just does not seem to be consistent
at all
which is super weird
like I don't know what to do about that
because
like what why does it sometimes compile
with those names
like what does that depend on
[Music]
is it
debug versus release Shader compiler
let me try something
so that was debug yeah let me try a
release because here's the funny thing
right
it doesn't like you it obviously it
caches the shaders
so
you can compile it in release
like as in using the release binaries of
the Shader compiler
and then switch your configuration debug
and it will read the cached copies that
were already compiled by the release
version even if you're in debug because
it doesn't matter obviously the result
is the same
if that's the case that's going to be
absolutely absurd
let's try this
[Music]
no way is this gonna happen
it's so fast as well look how fast that
was in release mode
oh my gosh it is guys
guys what the heck
so shade of C debug versus release
produces different variable names
and no I'm not talking about variable
names because that and and I'm not
talking about compiling the shaders with
optimization on so you're not compiling
the shaders in a different configuration
it's the Shader compiler binaries
that are on a debug versus a release
build
what the heck
that is absurd
that's so weird
let me just validate this real quick I
mean I'm pretty sure I'm right but let
me just confirm this
so if I just take this gtao Shader for a
bit let's just drag it up to the top and
let's like I don't know put a breakpoint
here
I'm gonna switch to debug
and then I'm going to delete my cached
compiled shaders and I'm going to hit F5
[Music]
so
foreign
yep so check this out so the name
of it in a debug so I'm in debug right
now right and the name is type Dot
constantbuffer.camera
and type dot constantbuffer.screen data
right
my other kind of variable names are fine
but the type kind of names are that yeah
and then if I switch to release
so I'm using the release like spur V
binaries and I run my code which will
compile the shaders in the same
configurations obviously it's just using
different spurvy but using a different
compiler binary
then
oh no it is still that what
wait did I delete the cache I didn't
like the cash right
what so now it's the same
but didn't it just work
now it doesn't work again
what
foreign
[Music]
it was working you saw hazelnut open
with without an issue
because the names were correct
but now they're wrong again
I thought it was debug best release but
it's not
what on Earth
[Music]
how
do I just try this again and it will
just work once eventually
this is ridiculous
I mean now it's gonna load the cached
versions
[Music]
Simon it's not even telling us what it
is because it's not compiling the
Traders again
what
[Music]
I don't understand
why it worked before
what was the difference
[Music]
there's there's no difference
there can't be any difference
[Music]
this is like the weirdest thing ever
foreign
[Music]
again it's only happening with the hlsl
shade is but like because some of our
shaders are jealous l
[Music]
ol what if it's
okay how about this
what if we put this back to where it was
so now it's down here
and now let's compile it
because that's the only other thing I
did
[Music]
I know it's silly but I don't know what
else to do
[Music]
let me know it's it's wrong
switch to debug real quick try it again
[Music]
this is so weird
unfortunately I had a way for everything
to compile here
but look the storage buffers look fine
the names oh look wait wait but what
about the rest of the uniform buffers oh
but no it's because it's not an hsl
these are glsl shaders that's why the
names are fine
because remember it's just an hlsl
Shader thing
[Music]
and yeah they're wrong
what if I just because I could also do I
think you can do force force compile so
if you do
and there's also optimization
we could try that as well so let's first
of all let's do a force compile
so now we don't have to delete the
shadow cache
that's wrong uh and let's do Force
compile but optimization
disable optimization true so that will
do not optimization just in case but to
take the reflection data from the null
optimized version anyway so I don't know
if this will produce a difference no it
doesn't
so they're always wrong here
and bro I don't get this at all
so weird
you guys saw it work though it worked
once
[Music]
we link different versions of dxc and
stuff right
like for debugging release
is
fair to see so yeah there's a there is a
different one but it doesn't seem to
matter there's a thing like now I just
don't get it because it's not like it my
theory seems to have been wrong
maybe I should watch back my live stream
and see what I did but
I don't think so
[Music]
that's so weird
ah
quiet
no
well
and say like the the run time is
different because the run time doesn't
compile any shaders it uses something
called a Shader pack which is like
that's the compiled kind of shaders
in like one binary file
along with like reflection data and
everything so that's what we that's what
we ship that's what the runtime is
but but I'm running the editor which can
compile shaders obviously and it's the
thing that creates these Shader packs
if you talk to
[Music]
that's so weird man this is so weird and
the thing is like obviously like by the
way like if I
like if this was in fact the the thing
like I could be like type dot constant
buffer.camera and
type.consumable.screen data and I think
pre-integration uh that kind of pass
also uses that
so
um I don't know what sets it though
but like if I run that
[Music]
like see that works because I changed
the way that we treat them
and so that will work
but
[Music]
the thing is only sometimes
so therefore
I don't know what to think
wait why is this working because aren't
we
using one
why is this working because
aren't we using one
like didn't we still
like the shadow Cascade thing
wasn't that just not working because it
was
everywhere oh no no it's because we're
using four Cascades here
because the editor has got a different
configuration
see that's red and it will change
create a plan or something
[Music]
sure I pressure plate another Spanish
sauce
incorrectly spelled pressure plate
now that's red
still you can see the different Shadow
Cascades on it
[Music]
I didn't fix it by the way guys like I
just changed the name to something that
doesn't work half the time
if it like it's fine if it was like that
forever that would be okay but the thing
is it doesn't it seems to like you saw
it randomly work before as well
as well which means that the name was
without the like type Dot
the name is sometimes this and sometimes
that
and I don't know why
[Music]
music
it's really weird
okay
um
to the wrong final release mode well it
runs fine in both modes now
let me just try and for fun
let's try and delete the shadow cache
and run again so this will
oh no way
where's the GTA oh Shadow guys
oh no that's correct
that's it
but it's saying it's not
and why are these null
what
what the heck is going on I've hit a
verify these are null somehow how they
null they get they get like created up
here
what's going on this is just possessed
what the heck
and my logging is not working nothing is
working
foreign
are you having a laugh
they get created like up here
and they're null apparently all of this
is null apparently
dude this is cooked
man man you know what let's do a clean
build
let's do a clean build
because this is like this is messed up
let's do a clean bit we're gonna we'll
do a clean a squeaky clean debug build
laughs
there is a back button in Visual Studio
it's up here top left or alt left Arrow
or the mouse
I just don't always use it because
sometimes it's a bit finicky
[Music]
foreign
this stream
what do you guys think of this kind of
live stream
I think it's uh pretty chill I mean I
always I've always done these kinds of
streams but just on Twitch not YouTube
thank you
[Music]
yeah so those names are consistent
foreign
[Music]
okay so this is now correct but why did
this not work
because the names are correct so let's
go into there now
we are in a debug build so we can do
that easily
I don't know why it's not logging though
foreign
[Music]
okay so this is what we expected because
the name is camera
wait why is the name
oh so now it's
but
bro what
but the reflection data says it's not
that
foreign
[Music]
what
but the reflection data says it's that
which is what I provided it with
look
see
but now
inside here
it's telling me
right
that the name
look
it doesn't have the type.constant buffer
wait
wait wait wait wait wait so maybe what's
printed here isn't necessarily what's
there but how it's literally the name
how can we be printing different things
how does it get these input input we're
getting closer guys
how's it getting these input
declarations
name okay it goes through Shader
descriptors it sets right descriptor
sets
and say it's it's different
so Shader descriptor write descriptor
sets
where does that get it from
welcome Trader resource
let's go to Vulcan Shader and see this
gets popped yay uniform of a name
uniform buffer name and uniform buffer
is where Traders represent uniform
buffers
where does that get come from
well potential this is for the shadow
packs it tries and rate it from the
binary but what about for not Shader
packs
it's got to be from Vulcan Shader right
oh sorry uh she had a compiler
right
uniform name resource name so yeah this
is coming from Valkyrie reflection no
but that doesn't make sense because
welcome Shadow Fight This Is Us printing
it
this is this is this and you can see
what the name is we're printing it
[Music]
look this isn't printing This Is Us
printing it name we use name to print it
the same name that's set here
wait is it because of this ridiculous
stupid map that we have that I should
have removed like two years ago
that basically makes sure that we don't
have any conflicts but no that can't be
it
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh I think I know what it is
but that doesn't make sense either
because the shaders are compiled in the
same order
it is I think it's because of this
Ah that's such a weird system
no no I think it's always that
I think the difference is that sometimes
because of this weirdo system that we
had since the opengl days
which isn't that weird but it kind of is
I think what what matters here
let's add some stuff here
that is a warning
[Music]
let's just say uniform buffer blah blah
so
[Music]
I mean that's just gonna be a name twice
but whatever
I'll be explicit
uh do we have a set descriptor set
binding
okay and then the difference here is
since that exists we check the name from
here I think I know what the deal is
[Music]
I don't think it's the fullback names
I think it's because
I think it's because it's whoever gets
to that binding and set first if it's a
glsl Shader then it's one name if it's
an hlsl Shader it's another name but
what I don't understand is that the
order should be predictable
so I think what will probably happen
here if we actually scroll up to the GTA
O Shader maybe I can quickly Beat It
I don't know if I beat it or not yeah ah
I missed it
but it doesn't matter I think
or maybe I didn't I did better
yep
say look
uniform buffer type dot concept of
camera at 2-0 already exists using name
camera
that's why it's always this name
but in this case it's using the name
camera because something else already
occupied slot 2-0 and the way that we
treat uniform buffers in Hazel again
because of the opengl days because if
you remember opengl is all weird about
global uniform buffers but Vulcan isn't
but still we we're kind of because so
many render passes use the same
descriptor sets we kind of basically
anything in descriptor set not zero
you only have one instance of it
basically so you're not you're not
allowed to put anything else in
descriptor set to binding zero apart
from this one buffer
that's why
so
[Music]
something else clearly so yeah so see
this same thing happened here but one of
these
guys created the camera
the first one would have but what I
don't understand is why clearly this
didn't seem to happen before when we ran
it I mean we did make remember we did
make GTA the first Shader and that
changed the behavior
and that makes sense but
so see the first thing to do it is the
PBR Shader
Hazel PBR static and because that's a
glsl Shader it just creates this the
name is camera
uh and that's it and now whatever we
look at slot 2-0 basically it has to be
called camera like well and even if it's
called something else it's going to take
the name camera
because that's what happens at the
moment
and it is a bit of a weird Behavior
because if you make a new Shader that is
completely custom and you for some
reason want to use set 2 for something
else but it's kind of reserved by the
renderer that's why
that's why you're not really allowed to
do that but if you were then this would
be a weird system and also like it does
technically work for set zero even
though it shouldn't because head zero is
owned by the material that's how we
treat it
and you can see we do this for uniform
buffers and storage buffers which is
kind of weird yeah
like again this is from open jail days
when basically they uniform buffers and
story buffers really were like this
they work on a global
um
but they're not obviously in Falcon
so that's what that's left over from
okay well I'm glad we got to the bottom
of that because that was ridiculous but
what I don't understand then
is why my code doesn't work if
if this is the first guy oh you know why
though
wouldn't it be because
of the
bro
oh my gosh I know why
that is the stupidest thing ever
it's because Vulcan Shader compiler
obviously compiles the code so if it's
already compiled it doesn't need to do
that
that's wild so what that means
basically is if I run this check this
out
if I run this in release this should
work perfectly right now yeah let's
check this out this is actually messed
up
if I run this okay it didn't work
perfectly oh that's because this is
wrong so let me go back to the normal
names yeah camera and Screen data
yeah let's run that this should work uh
let me delete the cache again
just to validate it but this should work
perfectly fine
yep we're up
no problems no no Vulcan validation
errors nothing everything's fine now if
I then yeah
go to the GTA O Shader
and make a change no matter how subtle
let's add a space yeah that will force a
recompile
but obviously the Hazel PBR Shader okay
that worked
I was sure that would fail
or maybe what if we change a macro
so what if I like I don't know
add another Mac no I bet the macro would
not
let's get rid of this now and let's try
and run this
will that work
because
but that should recompile all the
shaders shouldn't it
if the macros change
but that works as well
what if I change this to like one
aha now we're getting a set
yeah because
and yeah and you can see that's gonna be
an asset because of these guys now
and basically now it won't work on
unless I bring that back I think
yeah and see now it works
so now it works with these names
that is actually hilarious
now it works with these names
and the reason for that is because I
changed the macro and forced that Shader
to be recompiled not sure why the uh
it's not random code execution order
so this works now with this because I
deleted the Shader cache
but I guess if I go into here and I
change something but I tried that before
and it didn't didn't seem to recompile
it
but you know let's change this to be
like
I don't know eight
that's gonna recompile the shadow right
it has to surely
yeah and say that doesn't work
my space must have not made a difference
or something I don't know why I didn't
do that
oh
so basically guys don't
like but if you completely delete the
shadow cache then it's fine
but was it always fine
but if I go back to that that's gonna
break it
that plus the null termination bug was
what was causing all these problems no
that worked
but like the thing is or did it work
though it's that's black for some reason
because that like if you change a macro
I think it might have to recompile all
the shaders
that's not black anymore
oh that's that's weird man
your ID probably didn't save a change to
White space maybe but I feel like it
should have
so yeah
[Music]
all right
um well I'm glad that's kind of working
now wait so if I build
if I build the Shader pack now so let's
build the uh Shader pack
with so that will just compile
that will just create like a Shader pack
which is here you find now go into here
and this is where I'm running this right
if I overwrite that
and I go back to the run time
oh but the runtime with one Cascade
isn't gonna work at the moment no it is
apparently
maybe that's because I'm in release mode
[Music]
it's not doing that well my Shadows do
seem to be there
that's definitely a shadow that I see
here
[Music]
oh I almost made it
yeah I don't know
we basically have to yeah we have to I
think we have to trade shade of like we
have to add like some kind of Shader
variant system or something
so that we can properly like you know
properly deal with that
because otherwise
doesn't really make sense
how we would maybe support like having
just a single Shadow map
instead of like
cascaded Shadow mapping you know for a
game like this because you don't need
castigated Channel mapping
[Music]
oh yeah so remember we put a timer into
into
Bloom compute there it is I never showed
that because we couldn't get it running
but you can see it's very very uh fast
right 0.05 milliseconds of CPU time is
that entire
section of Bloom compute which does like
different compute shaded dispatchers to
do the down sampling and the up sampling
and that also allocates descriptor sets
and updates descriptor sets and you can
see it is 0.05 milliseconds like it's
it's very fast right
um
so that's why I like I wasn't too
concerned with it
but
because that's done once per you can
actually see it says one times this is
how many times these functions are
called
so you can stick a timer in any function
and it will tell you how many times it's
called as well as the the cumulative
like the the sum of all like the time
the sum of all the time that it took
within one frame obviously
so
[Music]
so yeah because it's done once per frame
it's fine
obviously because the bloom is like a
screen space effect but if it was
but like materials on the other hand
obviously kind of material and material
preparation has to happen per draw
so that's the difference and that's why
it was so important to optimize
do what I did before
we get a standalone executable of
hazeline in the near future
um a short answer yes but I don't know
about near future like I don't know when
exactly
but yes we are planning to do that
why is get assets so slow
uh well it's called 614 times
in one frame and it's not that slow it's
like 14 microseconds
have you guys thought about adding
bindless textures into durandra we have
that for path tracing but
um
like the thing is it's not really widely
supported as far as I'm aware
so like it's not really something it's
something you would only really have for
the top tier gpus I don't know maybe
that's changing maybe more drivers
supported these days but
it wasn't something that you could just
do everywhere because it requires some
Vulcan extensions
so that you can have like not descriptor
sets that are or descriptors that are
null
and stuff
how did you make your game engine so
fast
um I have a video that I put out 24
hours ago on my YouTube channel which
tells part of that story
now we're trying to join a game Jam
obviously not the next one lol with the
game engine that you have built from the
YouTube series or
maybe when it's more done
but yes maybe that would be kind of fun
I was gonna do that like it's gonna
maybe make like a Cherno dare
my own game jam and then have you guys
use like the free version of Hazel or
something
but that's in the future not quite now
[Music]
yeah Hazel has like there's a branch of
Hazel that has um path racing
uh using using like Vulcan RTX well
Vulcan Ray tracing
[Music]
are there functional differences between
dispatches in opengl and Falcon if
you're talking about like computer
dispatches uh well the thing is like
opengl like Vulcan allows you to the the
biggest difference probably apart from
how resources are handled using
descriptor sets is the fact that there's
like a there's an explicit compute cue
that you can use for dispatchers which
opengl is a bit more behind the scenes
with that
um and so what that means is that like
you don't have to you don't have to use
it like we actually don't use it in in
Hazel
um so in other words all of our computer
Traders actually are submitted to the
graphics queue uh which is not not ideal
but it's easier
um to deal with because obviously it's
kind of like it's not multi-threaded in
a while it's not it's not kind of like
multi-threaded or parallel on the GPU
because if it's on the graphics queue it
all kind of happens one after the other
but if you
if you are doing stuff concurrently if
you are submitting it to the compute
queue and the graphics queue is
obviously running concurrently to that
you need some extra synchronization
which I haven't really looked into much
in Hazel yet
um but that's like one difference I
guess
there's not that many differences
because it's you know the thing with
these apis like open gel and Falcon is
that at the end of the day it's kind of
like the actual like it's kind of up to
the GPU driver to implement all the
behavior anyway so the thing is like GP
the GPU side of things like you
basically have the same feature set
what's really different about Vulcan is
the CPU side of things because obviously
the API is different and the API is what
you write in C plus plus so like that
part is is very different but what the
GPU is doing like you still have the
same shaders you still have the same
like it's still kind of the driver still
does a lot of the similar a lot of a lot
of similar things so really the biggest
performance boost is going to be on the
on the CPU but then you also get like
you know Ray tracing which I don't know
if there are Ray tracing extensions for
opengl I don't really think there are
there are there are at least not all of
them
um but like you know that that they're
also vendor specific
does it have any denoiser for Ray
tracing or just Bare Bones no no deniser
yet
but yeah again I was explaining that the
reason why I started working on pass
racing and uh ngi and stuff in Hazel was
because we were going to make a game
that would use that Tech but we're
making a different game now so
Studio Channel I mean so therefore
we don't really need it and I moved on
to other things because there's lots of
other stuff to do but that was fun and
I'll get back to that eventually
ah could you make a video teaching how
to make how to create a GUI in C plus I
watched two other videos on that but I
was too confused to know how to use it
well I have that best way to make
desktop applications in the same as this
video I thought that was pretty
straightforward
maybe give that a watch on a half speed
am I going to continue the right racing
stories yes eventually
[Music]
um but not uh
not I've been busy obviously with other
things that's why I haven't been doing
that
is Vulcan rage raising and Hazel used
for baking light Maps or is it real time
it's uh well the version that I have is
not used to baking light Maps yet it
will be
but uh it is it's kind of real time like
it it's kind of
like it's not it still takes it still
accumulates over different frames but
it's a lot faster than like the ray
tracing series because it's this is
running in on RTX cores
there's okay let's I guess we can wind
it down the stream because I'm pretty
tired and I'm gonna go home
um so I'll let's I can do a bit of a q a
now q a stream
for the last like 10 minutes or so
[Music]
okay
so ask ask your questions
um
let's see let's position them in a
decent spot
[Music]
maybe a bit off topic about what was the
moment when you decide to start
recording videos instead of just solo
deving um well I actually started making
videos basically as I started learning
programming so
like 12 years ago in 2011 when I picked
up Java for dummies and I started like
learning programming basically three
months later I started making videos
being like hey what's up guys let me
show you what I've been learning and
also teach it to you
um and that's kind of when it began so
basically immediately
I was like 16 at the time
well you still use twitch um I don't
know like I've kind of been uh
I've kind of been into the YouTube
streaming lately I don't know why it's
just something new
um
and yeah it's been nice you know most of
my most of my audiences on YouTube you
can stream into high quality on YouTube
you can rewind streams
just kind of and the vods stay up
obviously and it's just kind of nice to
stream on YouTube to be honest for those
of you who like want me to stream on
Twitch can I ask why like what is it
because obviously like there's no
difference for me
because I don't
it's just like do I stream to YouTube or
twitch like on you know in my streaming
software it's the same thing but like
and like obviously there are some
features that are different like you can
read streams and do whatever on Twitch
but aside from that like what's the
difference like to the to the viewer of
of my streams because I watch other
streams but for that yeah see the the
twitch ads thing is huge that sucks
like you basically watch like four ads
in a row on Twitch when I look at
someone else's stream
so that's really annoying
um YouTube is better
well yeah like I mean I I like you I
think I like YouTube more
I mean I know I know I'm streaming on
YouTube and asking people if they like
YouTube more and it's a bit biased but
like you know I don't I don't think that
if you're watching the stream on YouTube
You're necessarily loyal to YouTube
[Music]
um
was it hard to migrate your render
engine to MD gpus because I'm thinking
of making my engine more GPU across
platform and if it's worth the effort
uh it wasn't hard but it did it did take
like a week I think when I eventually
bit the bullet and got my got an AMD GPU
like for the office
and actually Tim used to use that but
Tim has since switched to a 1080 TI
because he's had enough of AMD
um and I'm not exaggerating like his
Photoshop was crashing and flickering
black sometimes like Photoshop you know
and it and you know I was like and he
was like just being like really annoyed
at Adobe and I mean rightfully sorry
because Adobe like I mean Premiere Pro
is the worst software in the world and I
hate it so much and DaVinci is so much
better but anyway
um
I was like I was like no that's probably
not Adobe like just slap in the 1080 TI
and he just slapped it in
I've restarted his computer and that's
it gone fixed so um Tim had enough of
that but we do have we still we'll still
do have it in one of our computers that
we basically use like for testing and
stuff
um
and uh but initially when we first got
it like yeah I spent like a week because
I basically booted up Hazel I think I
got a few Falcon validation errors that
were new but also the biggest problem
was that like it just looked weird like
well okay there were two problems one of
them was there were weird black
triangles everywhere which if you
actually I think watched the early days
of uh Tim like because because it was on
because Tim had it on his computer he
had the AMD card in his computer so when
he like was working on Forest I think
for
like a lot of 50. um he there was like
these weird black triangles
in places and I think that's just
because something was wrong with our
shadow map and I forgot exactly what the
problem is but we fixed that
um I managed to track that down uh but
initially I think the biggest problem
was Bloom was really weird like it was
like ghosting like it looked like it was
you'd move the camera and it was like
smearing around and the reason why that
was the case is because I had no image
barriers between my compute dispatches
even though I was reading the last map
and writing to the next map in the in
the same kind of image and so I guess
Nvidia was just like show man like I see
what you're trying to do I know you like
have missed half the code you needed to
actually write to make that happen but I
got you I got you fam like you're you're
good but then AMD is like screw you man
I'm gonna I'm not I don't have your back
I'm AMD you better write better code so
and that's the thing like you can't like
for those things you can't really blame
AMD because like yes according to the
Vulcan spec I should have done this and
that but it's nice that Nvidia like
Nvidia is a homeboy like Nvidia has your
back you know and that's just why I
think they're Superior all right have
you tested on an Intel GPU before yes it
doesn't work
um we have some issues with Intel gpus
but I do want to do that eventually
how deep do you think you're going to go
with your ray tracing series
um
oh I don't know like I would love to go
really deep
but I can't in good conscious conscience
in good conscience
make that business decision because like
real talk here like those really super
deep Niche kind of technical videos they
don't really make the company any money
like it's like very on it's very not
profitable for me and I say the company
because like obviously like Studio
channel is like you know we're a
business like we you know we have Peter
here in in chat who desperately needs
his paycheck to survive we have Tim
who's like been living on the street and
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding no
one's living on the streets but the
point is they will be if I don't make
money and so and then obviously like
this office space is not gonna
pay rent itself so the the point is like
as much as I'd love to you know have no
concern for any of that like I still
need to run this as a business and those
kind of like really In-Depth series like
they just don't get the views they don't
get the kind of like I know you guys are
really appreciative of it and I love
making them like to be honest I love
making them even if it is I'd add a
little bit of a loss so to speak like I
like making them but the thing is like
what I've kind of realized I think is
that in the future if I do stuff like
that maybe I should just sit down and
make like a a complete finished kind of
Premium course you know not like an 800
course you know not something like that
is completely not accessible to anyone
but maybe like a I don't know like a
50.99 kind of course you know something
like less than a hundred dollars
probably that is obviously complete so
that you're not waiting for episodes and
also that way like I'd probably justify
spending that much time on it
so that's kind of like you know the ray
tracing series will still continue I'm
not gonna just halfway through the ray
tracing Series be like oh yeah pay me
money now but like in the future if I do
do kind of really in-depth Niche kind of
series like that which I would love to
do like I just don't think YouTube's a
place for it like it just doesn't really
work
so
um
that's why like
that's why I kind of
can't really focus on that stuff and
like the thing is obviously like I know
that a lot of like the loyal kind of
people who are maybe here to learn and
they love that kind of stuff like I
think that's a bit of a shame but at the
end of the day like it is kind of and I
know that those videos are sponsored and
stuff but it is kind of free content and
the thing is the way that YouTube works
and the way that YouTube is kind of
um
set up is that like I mean you guys see
the kinds of videos that are very
successful on YouTube like
a lot of the time I like a lot of the
times it's kind of like
[Music]
um
it's just like entertaining kind of
short form videos
um
you know even like like with my own kind
of experience in mind
when I've made videos like a lot like
okay this is the other really
frustrating thing right like a lot of
the times and I think I've mentioned
this on live streams before but whatever
like a lot of the times I will work my
ass off for like weeks on a video and
I'll make it it's really good video yeah
and like and and it'll get like x amount
of views and then the next day I'll just
make myself like
with no preparation just kind of like
almost vlogging but like you know just
like reading some code or like doing
like a code review live obviously like
it live in the sense that like I have
never read the code before no
preparation required I sit down hit
record quickly edit it I can be done
within like
I don't know maybe takes me like 20
minutes like half an hour to record half
an hour to edit because I usually add it
on like two times speed and stuff
one hour of work and it will get like
five times the views of like a video
that I might spend like
Wixom
and it's just like
and that's fine because obviously in a
way that means that you guys enjoy that
content more I guess maybe
but it's it also means that like the
fact of the matter is that there are way
less people like more people want to
just open up a YouTube video of probably
like you know me just doing a code
review and just something they can kind
of watch while they're having dinner or
just in their break or in bed or
whatever versus like on their phones
versus like sitting down to do a ray
tracing course
you know that's just like it's just a
different amount of people and that just
means that unfortunately it's just not
like
you know it it's not it's not a good
business decision for me and of course
it's not all about the money it's not
all about like you know if it was then
some of the stuff that I do on YouTube
really really wouldn't exist but you
know now that I have a team and stuff
and like we want to do stuff right we
want to make games we want to make games
and you know that requires
people that requires money so that's
also the kind of thing
um and we want to keep working on Hazel
as well
all right uh that was a long answer well
we saw it on udemy no I want to make my
own platform because udemy like
depending on how you
depending on what you do on udemy udemy
can take up to like 70 or 80 of the
money
I think it might even be more
so I'm gonna be making like I don't know
I don't know Cherno Academy or something
and it's just gonna be like 100 of the
proceeds are going to go to Studio
Channel
[Music]
um all right
and also like I don't need the I don't
need you to miss marketing I think that
I can just Market it on YouTube
obviously to you guys
but like yeah just like I the thing is I
don't have time though right now I would
love to make a course on so many things
like I really want to make a an updated
more complete C plus plus course because
I have obviously the one on YouTube but
that's like you know I've I started out
in 2017 like I've learned so much
obviously in the last six years that I
would read I would redo it and I would
also probably make it more complete so
that's something I want to do and I want
to make that like
fairly cheap just so that like more
people can learn C plus plus you know
um and then like I'd love to do like a
Vulcan course but not like a Vulcan
Vulcan course meaning how to use Vulcan
the API but more like how to actually
build a renderer in Vulcan and render
like a beautiful scene like I really
want to do that as well
um
yeah like a ray tracing kind of thing
would be cool but I'm I'm kind of doing
that on YouTube but I don't know to what
extent I'll end up doing that and we'll
see how it goes because that's not a
high priority
um but
yeah like
I would love to sit down and just take a
year and make like a bunch of courses
but I also have to keep this going and
obviously like I have a family I have a
baby
um so like I can't just work you know
forever
oh by the way thank you bewilder beast
for the five pounds
I appreciate all the free content thank
you I appreciate you appreciating the
free content
[Music]
it wasn't like 30 of you to be in 70 of
the Creator it depends if you sell it
with a coupon I think you do get most of
it but if you if you said no if you sell
it through your own link so udemy gives
you a link as far as I'm aware I've
never sold anything on udemy so I don't
know but
this is what I've heard
um if you sell it through a coupon
through your coupon then you get like 80
I don't know how much but you get the
majority but if udemy sells it through
their site meaning that someone on udemy
didn't go through your link but found
your course and paid for it you didn't
get the majority
but still even if they took thirty
percent like why I'd rather price the
course lower
and give it and you know have it be
cheaper for you guys and have more
people who might not be able to afford
expensive courses have access to it
foreign
[Music]
how to get a job in the games industry
um well I've told my story before
it's a little story time with Cherno
but um I don't know if I like really
know how to get a job in the games
industry I just kind of stumbled into it
somehow so
uh yeah
I don't really have much experience with
that if I was making that video it's
probably mostly for the clickbait let's
be real because I don't really you know
what I don't really know what I would
say
well well I mean I could give advice
obviously like you know here's the video
in like five seconds have a good strong
portfolio uh of like what you've
actually done so that when you rock up
at an end to an interview or whatever
you can be like hey check out this like
game engine I made check out Hazel like
I just made this game engine called
Hazel we've shipped games with it like
you know want to play one of them here
look at it running at 500 FPS done
where do I start
do something like that
just want to let you know as simple as
training videos are very appreciated
thank you
make them with a lot of exercises yes
that's the other thing if I was making a
c plus like a premium C plus course I
would make it
um yeah like I'd I would make it I would
you know have homework next because see
that's the other thing right like on
YouTube it's like people watch YouTube
videos they're not as committed but if
someone buys like a 50 course you know
like they obviously like they're
committed right like they're gonna go
they've bought it because they really
want to learn and they're willing to pay
money for it right so therefore like
those people you know like it'd be
really cool having like all those people
in like a Discord where they can it kind
of like basically like the idea that I
the reason why I came up with this by
the way guys is because
is because like
I so I teach students right a lot of you
guys don't know this but the channel.com
tutoring right or if you just go to the
channel.com there's like like a link
there but the thing is I teach
I teach people privately and I never
announce this I never talk about this
because obviously if I'm teaching people
like you know if people book in our
sessions with me that's an hour of my
time so I clearly can't like scale that
because if I scale that then I have no
time to make videos or work on Hazel
because I'm teaching students full-time
so I never announced this so it's like
you know for those of you who want me to
teach you privately like good luck and
it sounds like I'm being like arrogant
or whatever but I'm just being realistic
like it's tough like I don't have many
open slots but anyway the point is I'm
not saying this because it's an ad for
my tutoring business I'm saying this
because
um
recently I've been teaching this one
student who goes to University
and like they like
are studying C plus plus there
and basically I've been helping them
like with their kind of homework and
their assignments
and my gosh do I want to pull my hair
out like I was just thinking like the
stuff that they are doing there is
actually like
it's it's it's just messed up like it is
just wild
and I was just like
and and like I'm obviously teaching this
student and like I'm explaining stuff to
them and they're like wow like you've
you've like I can't believe you just
explained that in five minutes like my
lecturer did not say any of this like
and and it turns out in about an hour
like I I literally taught this student
more than like they had learned in
probably over a week
especially because like you know they
can Google stuff themselves and they can
learn themselves and I get that like a
lot of these you know courses in in
University are all about self learning
but like still like the the assignments
that they got and what they had to do
you know
was just
so specific and not broad at all like
one of the assignments was I kid you not
implementing a like I think some kind of
like hash map but it wasn't implementing
a hash map it was writing a class that
wrapped SCD on ordered map
I'm not kidding
how to write how to write your own
hashmap class make a class called
hashmap add a bunch of functions and
then just have it call STD on ordered
map like bro what are you doing
like anyway that was just one of the
examples and then like I think the other
thing was like making a calculator in WX
widgets
and I'm like first of all thank you
student for making me try out WX widgets
a thing I have never done before and
we'll never do again
um but like
calculator
in WX widgets to learn C plus plus guys
not like let's make a fun game like you
know just using the command line to
learn about like data structures and how
to like you know balance like how do you
know how to like you know allocate
memory and store State and logic to make
that work none of that no no no no no
like let's use like sfml or sdl or
something like this is how you use a
library in C plus plus and look graphics
on the screen isn't this exciting and
don't you just want to add more features
to this
a calculator
in WX widgets
which
is just
ridiculous
and so the thing is the reason why I'm
telling you a story is because of that
because of this student like I
legitimately
was just like bro
I want to make my own like C plus plus
University course because I would teach
this so much better and like I bet a
bunch of you guys would teach you so
much better it's not that I'm so good
it's just that like I honestly think
that
it's just ridiculous what they're doing
like I just can't just do get I just
don't get it how is that useful bro how
is that useful you're going to graduate
college or university and you're going
to be like hey like potential job person
who wants to hire me I can make a
calculator in WX widgets
first of all who who even uses wxpit
like who who I'm not saying it's an
office is a very popular Library I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
like who graduates University
armed with WX widgets and like puts that
on their resume and it's like I'm gonna
now become a WX widgets programmer does
anyone actually want to do that with
their lives
like it doesn't make sense
but also you're clearly learning how to
use WX widgets you're not learning how
to and in the scope of a calculator as
well like you're not learning C plus
plus really
so anyway the point is like I was just
like bro like let me just make my own
University
let me just make my own University I'll
make some really good C plus plus
content I'll give you really good
exercises we're gonna make projects that
like inspire you and that you're gonna
wanna sit down and work on
and you're gonna actually learn how to
think like a programmer and you're going
to learn the language and you're going
to learn how to do whatever you want to
do instead of how to do this one
specific task
so that's my sales pitch now I just need
someone to give me time
I just need to be like I just need to
retreat to a cabin for like six months
like some kind of artist and just make
this thing
I rest my case
[Music]
I'll take questions now thank you
you will make University
I don't know about that
did I say that
but yeah
how to join your Halo team as a
programmer uh well we're not exactly
hiring and like I like usually the
people on the Hazel core team who are
volunteers the way that they kind of
joined
is
um
they basically like did stuff
like they basically became patrons they
got access to the code base and then
they did stuff and then they were like
hey Channel check this out
so like Emily for example who's in chat
like she's the newest member like
she basically just added Linux support
to Hazel
and we're just like here and then like
you know I put Peter in charge of that
just because I had no time to deal with
that
but like you know she did a pretty good
job and Ashley and Hazel team
so that's how that works
um
and like you know it's it's just that
like obviously like I can't just be like
oh you want to be in the hill you want
to work on Hazel Shore done like because
you know we need to support some kind of
level of code people pay for hazel right
people pay for access to Hazel so like I
do want to have some kind of level of
quality
um
but yeah and people have interns as like
volunteers and stuff but again like you
know you can always try sending me an
email like to business at the
channel.com but like
you have to also
uh realize that like obviously every
kind of person that I even if you are a
volunteer and I'm very grateful for your
kind of contribution that's still like
it's not necessarily
uh it doesn't necessarily make things
easier
especially if you're not very good which
I mean is a possibility
so yeah
I'm already an experienced programmer do
you have any suggestions for learning C
plus plus
um yeah just like start using it for
whatever you want to use it for and just
Google stuff along the way
it's like you know
I mean there are there are important
things for you to realize in C plus plus
like really like the biggest thing is
probably just like memory and stuff
memory pointers that kind of stuff
that's probably the biggest thing and
obviously the like the library
but other than that it's not really that
different different from other sister
languages how big is the Hazel team
well there's three people in studio
Channel myself Tim and Peter and that's
like the kind of paid people who have
jobs
um
but then the volunteers there's
probably like four at four people at the
moment who are kind of active right
it's a zero x j Emily now
is that it three
I think that's it
Miss himself primer of your own
materials there well if you're already
an experienced programmer I don't know
if my C plus series would help I guess
it would though because like especially
at the beginning of those videos on like
how the C plus compiler Works how to say
about Linker Works move semantics like
yeah there's probably some there's
probably a lot of videos there that are
kind of not just for programming like
the variables video but like uh you know
and functions or whatever but like
specifically for C plus plus and that'd
be good
uh someone said something about alifka I
think
oh here we go
videos
um yeah I speak Russian uh and that
question was like
you speak and understand Russian
basically there was a question though
um alifco is the name of my cat by the
way Olive I guess in English
um but anif because it's just a nice
name
foreign
ly have it at University I hate it yeah
it doesn't it's I hate it so much like
why man
the thing is like I honestly think that
like and I'm not it's not an
exaggeration it took me like an hour it
took me like an hour to set up this
stupid WX widgets like it literally took
me so long and like you know I mean
unless I was actually because because
here's what I did right I downloaded
like I I am not kidding by the way I
downloaded WX widgets like I downloaded
the development libraries and that like
the header files or whatever
and they come with Visual Studio
property pages
so like it should work but it doesn't
man get added into your property manager
in Visual Studio
and it's like it just doesn't compile
so it took me like an hour to manually
go through the property pages and like
fix the configuration that it shipped
with apparently
so like
like why
why doesn't just work
and like it's so weird like it has its
own like main function like somewhere
that you include and like lots of macros
everywhere to like bind events and stuff
like yeah some of that stuff makes sense
but it's also like
no one learning C plus plus needs to be
exposed to that that's maybe like a
third year subject
because it's complex and it doesn't make
sense and it teaches you that c plus
looks ridiculous because the thing about
C plus plus is it's so flexible that it
can be made to look and be used however
you like and so people create different
libraries that almost look like
different languages
[Music]
which is fine if you're experienced
but like if you're not then
that's crazy
[Music]
WX which is more commonly used on Linux
sure
yeah I'm gooey is definitely the easiest
way oh that's definitely true like I
think it's a good idea if I like but but
the thing is I also don't think that you
need to be making GUI applications in
like University if you're like of course
if you're doing just like a computer
science degree and then maybe like you
know a second third year like sure you
know have a subject on on guise not bad
but like first year like
no
do something fun first of all and second
of all do something more useful that
will teach you the language not the
library
because I guarantee anyone who picks up
WX widgets in their first year of civil
plus it's going to be like bro what an
outdated language especially if they use
other things
openglow Vulcan uh well I like Vulcan
more
but yeah
opengl's fine uh you can still kind of
use it I think I think it's not too
outdated or like drivers drivers driver
support's still decent I guess maybe
if you're wanting to build a UI just use
C sharp WPF yeah well if you're using C
sharp then I guess so but that's also
like kind of specific because you've got
xaml
um and you need to like you know data
binding and like that's why like I don't
know I'm gooey really is simple in the
sense that like it's very Bare Bones
it's just like because it's immediate
mode I think it makes more sense than
anything else because if you have if
you're already used to say plus plus and
you have like your data structures and
you you know how to use like I don't
know maps and vectors and whatever in C
plus plus then like getting that to be
displayed now on the screen in the form
of UI you know I'm GUI is just like
easy you just iterate through your data
structure and draw stuff because it's in
Media mode but with like you know qt or
like you know cute as people call it but
whatever with like QT I'm just gonna
call it QT
um and like WPF and so I'm not saying
example is bad I'm just saying that it's
like
you know it's it's going straying
further from like obviously C plus plus
and that simple way of things
um
you know
you kind of end up you know you have to
make your own you have to convert it
into their data structures potentially
and it just becomes a whole thing
and you know with I don't know if xaml
and WPF is still kind of like all like I
know there's like you know with a data
binding and then there's like notify
property changed and then like there's
all this other stuff that you have to
add and because I did quite a lot of
xaml and C sharp WPF for EA
uh like I wrote entire Tools in it
actually
I wrote a model viewer and a Sprite like
a Sprite a 2d Sprite animator like with
a compression system I did both like the
the like workflow and the the
development side of things meaning like
the what the
what the the game studios used to
actually create these and author these
Sprite animations and then I also did
the runtime
so that was a big system
[Music]
and yeah the the tools were written in C
sharp WPF and Frostbite is C Sharp WPF
by the way a lot of people don't know
that a lot of people think it's like
unreal and unity which is like you know
just C plus plus and stuff but it's not
C shop WPF
why choose Vulcan over DirectX 12 if
using MFC and other windows stuff anyway
if they're upset are the if they're
upsides Falcon versus direct 21 I guess
12 from just the API perspective no
there's not I would use DirectX 12.
um I used Vulcan because of two reasons
uh first of all it is the best bang for
buck meaning that for implementing one
API you immediately get all the desktop
platforms and even more right so Windows
Mac Linux Mac via molten VK so Falcon
1.2 now is supported basically
automatically of course not ideal of
course would be better to use metal on
Mac but you still get it nonetheless and
then you get Windows and Linux
um which I would say are the two big
gaming kind of platforms Windows of
course is 98 or whatever of that but
still you get the desktop platforms and
that's good because even though like
most people aren't tripping games on
Linux meaning like most Gamers I guess
aren't on Linux a lot a lot of
developers like Linux and so that means
that Hazel could potentially be a tool
tool that they could use for development
and for data visualization and for other
things not necessarily shipping games
but just using the editor and being able
to experiment with like shaders or
rendering or whatever they want to do so
that's kind of why but also I mean
Android which not we don't care about
really because we don't want to really
support mobile but also the Nintendo
switch which Vulcan is not the native
API for that but you can
like ship games with Vulcan on the
Nintendo switch and we do want to Target
that one day so basically
realistically it gets us four platforms
whereas obviously DirectX gives us
windows and Xbox and the Windows phone
which I don't think it exists anymore
but uh
I remember back at EA we supported that
for The Sims
up until that got canceled but yeah
um
so that's why that's basically why
but that doesn't mean that we're never
going to add DirectX 12 support it
should be fairly easy and I don't mean
easy easy but like comparatively easy
just because it's very similar to Vulcan
and uh we support and we like the engine
mostly you know obviously
kind of a works
like we've abstracted a lot of stuff
that Falcon does so
it should be okay
but it would like for us to ship it
DirectX 12 game like if we basically
DirectX 12 is going to be added to Hazel
if we seriously decide to Target the
Xbox which if that ever happens that
will be once we ship a game on Steam
like a premium game on Steam and let's
just say does really well and you guys
all buy it and you love it and it does
really well and we have some more
resources then we're gonna make we're
gonna we might Port it to Xbox
yeah
and that would be cool
is less support part of Hazel 2023.1 no
it'll be part of 2023.2
what was your most learned resource when
learning Graphics
um so initially I
initially I think the biggest resource
in the very beginning for me was the
opengl Super Bible
so that's a book that I bought with
which I have a physical copy of which is
like this thick and it teaches you a lot
about the API as well as how to do
certain render techniques
um and then there was like the book of
shaders as well like the red book or the
orange book whatever it's called um that
was I didn't I don't have a physical
copy of that but that was useful
um after that it was EA my experience at
EA and being able to talk to people at
EA and be like how the heck do I make
this better
um
and also
basically at the end of my first year at
EA in 2015 uh we were porting the engine
to Vulcan and actually when I first
joined EA we were adding PBR support to
our mobile engine called Osiris
um so I was exposed I was around a lot
of Graphics stuff and uh
once we had the PBR stuff working later
that year was basically yeah Vulcan we
had like
pre-production or pre-release Falcon
drivers that rebooted Android devices
every time we'd make an incorrect API
call
very fun
um but I was uh kind of around that a
lot so I learned a lot of that as well
and I could talk to people
what does PS5 use for API basically uses
two genome GNX one of them's kind of
like open jail one of them is kind of
like Vulcan
uh what are your yeah so if we did PS5
we'd have to implement Sony's API but
um it's not too bad and the development
tools are fantastic
meaning like the it's kind of like in a
way it's almost like apple apple stuff
like like apple like you know like metal
with xcode works really really well like
you can do really good frame caps
captures it's kind of like having
randodok and inside just in your IDE
like it works really well and I know
that like in a way
um
Visual Studio has like DirectX some kind
of DirectX debugger but I've never used
it
Channel I found out that patreon isn't
legally available in Russia could you
make an alternative way to see videos
from it yeah I've had a few people from
Russia reach out
um I don't know I just don't know how to
make that work but like I would like to
maybe send me like a
an email
and I'll try and do something but like
yeah it's it's unfortunate
uh Hey channel did you ever use the go
to keyword in your seatbel's career
ah not in like production code or
anything but probably I have just for
fun I guess you don't really need it
like it simplifies something it's like
if you have like uh if you want to break
out of more than one if more than one
for Loop you know for example like you
have a nested for Loop and you're in the
inner one and you want to break out of
both it's really annoying to set that up
that's one of the few things that are
like in terms of how control flow Works
in programming like that sucks which is
why when my boss at EA was writing his
own language called words
um I suggested that he make this new
keyword called flee
and flee like FL f l double e and you
could specify a number next to it so
you'd be like flee 2. and Fleet 2 is
kind of like break but it breaks out of
two scopes
pretty cool idea I gotta get a pattern
on that
what do you think about random
dependency graphs um yeah they're good I
mean Hazel kind of has a render graph
now ish it's like half of half a
randograph so we can kind of do that
which is good
two
um
there is Boosty patreon alternative I
haven't heard of that
oh yeah maybe we can just use a VPN
that'd be nice
I imagine
um will you ever Hazel source code for
the public probably not
um because that's how we funded the
project
if you if you guys didn't support the
project on patreon then Tim and Peter
would not be employed
and I don't even know if and even me
like maybe I could survive off of like
YouTube ads and sponsorships but like I
probably wouldn't have quit my job at EA
if it wasn't for you guys so
uh that's that's the thing Hazel Hazel
exists as long as people pay for it
it's really that simple
I'd still do it for fun obviously if I
was still working at EA and I wasn't
making any money from this then um I'd
still work on Hazel but obviously the
progress would be much slower because
I'd be working full time at EA and
outside of that you know having a family
and raising children and stuff
so yeah
Linux gaming is going to be hard to get
off the ground properly because there
isn't enough critical mass
yes
yeah the payment from Russia wouldn't
even work with VPN that's true
time to escape from Russia I think
Tony plays says I am paying Peter's
salary so Peter better help me if I need
some help yes
that's how it works we divide the
employees
into the patreon into patrons
but we give we give
a portion to each patreon
ABI breaks and C plus plus that's a
flame War
hey what about Linux plus Hazel how's
this relationship today pretty good
works
I'm going to uh well actually I haven't
physically like in In the Flesh I
haven't actually seen it work
um
Peter has seen it work I believe he has
a Linux computer at home which he has
run it on successfully
um but I do have poppy behind me which
if you guys watched yesterday's video
you know that I made this new or got
this new QA computer and named it Poppy
very uh spare of the moment decision for
the naming but um
uh I'm gonna install Linux on Poppy
and uh
then I'll be able to see it work in the
flesh
and hopefully we're gonna
fix um
well ship the uh our whatever game we
make for the game Jam next weekend
hopefully I want to ship that on Linux
Maybe not immediately but eventually
[Music]
doesn't work late as Dev I worked a few
commits ago yes we had some uh drama
amongst the Hazel team
and that's why Linux doesn't work on the
latest commit
didn't involve me
I'll say that much how often do you
stream I don't know man
I don't know I try and stream like once
a week
will I make a schedule in the future
here on you for last year's
um yeah I guess so
uh I
um
yeah I mean I can schedule live streams
so I'll probably schedule the let them
there I'm gonna do a lot of their live
stream on YouTube I think so I'll
schedule that like a few days ahead of
time so you guys can kind of see that
but yeah
why do you favor Visual Studio because
instead of other ideas like c-line
because it's better than them
um are you in an office or your own home
I'm in I'm in the studio Channel office
need a link to this music playlist it's
just epidemic sound and it's just Jazz
I've said the genre to Jazz and that's
what we're listening to
what about Vulcan 3D rendering course
one day when I have time
I'm excited to see what you do for the
game Jam so am I I was thinking of using
Hazel but I'm not sure if I will be able
to get anything made in this
well it's definitely possible to make
stuff with it because we have done that
but yeah
do you plan on adding multiplayer on
Hazel yes but I don't know when
I plan on adding everything to Hazel but
it's just like I might be doing it when
I'm like on my pension but I will be
doing it
um do you recommend learning Vulcan just
by reading the docs no I wouldn't read
the official the official documentation
is good to have as a reference but yeah
I would not read it uh to learn Vulcan
just I don't know like
vulcentutorial.com or whatever
do that and then Sasha Williams examples
are fantastic
that's all you need really I think
if you don't understand rendering at all
then that's tough
like you'll have to probably look at
another source which I can't help you
with because I I will make that Source I
will make that Resource One Day
I hope to be the one of the the better
guides for rendering and stuff at least
to learn that and get started but I need
time for that
new game engine in HTML when that's
funny
anyway I should probably go it's like
pretty late
but
it's kind of fun
I feel like YouTube streams are more fun
I don't know why
does Hazel how has a functionality that
no other engine has oh
I don't know
not really I guess you could probably
achieve anything you can achieve in
Hazel and other engines as well
but Hazel is just like to be honest the
best thing about hazel is just how fast
it is like to iterate over and stuff
like because it's kind of small and
simple like you know you can just like
you can just like
update a c-sharp script like live pretty
much like without even stopping like in
play mode actually Peter does that still
work
because that's a really good feature I
was doing that in my Ray tracing Series
in one of the in like one of the
episodes where I show how it actually
like how this stuff works
um I was just using Hazel and I was
reloading like C sharp scripts as I was
writing them like really quickly
um and it was just working so
annoying line about chat
I've just noticed that
um but anyway
[Music]
um where were we
I think it should says Peter that's good
yeah hot reload like yeah like you know
the thing is like working with unity
like everything's just so slow like if
you change something you go back you see
a little progress bar it like recompiles
like the whole editor or whatever it
does and 10 minutes later you're playing
whereas with hazel it's just like done
hitting play and stop is very fast as
well like it's just like because it's so
simple it's just really fast and it's
just a like when it works it's a
pleasure honestly it's a pleasure to
work with because of just how
lightweight and fast I guess it is
but when it doesn't work it's annoying
because you like crap I have to add half
the features I want
you agree the code is better than
blueprint making I prefer it but I'm a
programmer so
would I really say anything else
probably not
we'll like stable releases bills of
Hazel be like free in the future
um I like I use the word like twice in
that sentence uh yeah we want to make a
free book like we want to make
um like binary releases of like hazel
free uh in the future but I don't know
when
and so basically the plan that like the
future plan is like hazel will be free
to use but if you want the source code
then you're going to have to support it
on patreon
that's basically the the gist and you'll
also get like I guess the latest version
obviously the development version
through patreon because you'll get
access to the repository and then we'll
do periodic releases like probably once
a quarter
I haven't touched unity in about 10
years is it really that bad now
um it's pretty bad yeah I don't like it
how do you make money off of Hazel
patreon.com thank you Ray for your
support on that platform
um
Unity sometimes breaks for me yeah it
breaks for everyone
the thing I hate the most and unreal is
that I have to Recon populate it at all
time yeah like unreal is good and their
Tech is great obviously but
like my goodness me
[Music]
um
like my goodness me is it's like just
like you know compiling 6 000 shaders
for my simple scene of a plane in the
cube like no thank you
but like that being said I do like
Unreal Engine because it is really good
but um the thing is it's more of like
AAA engine like and even though it's
kind of they're trying to make it I
guess more Indie like it really is a
hardcore engine
which compiler is used to compile Hazel
and Y msvc because Windows is the best
um but in all seriousness uh I haven't
really tried compiling like I know that
we can compile it with clang because
obviously we spot Linux and we compile
it on I think we use clang or GCC Maybe
I don't know which one Peter is Linux
bottle of clang
I think we use clang but anyway
um we can obviously compile it on clang
on Windows but I haven't tried that so
we should we should actually do that
because I don't know who knows it might
be faster like as in dichotomy might be
faster compiled and clang who knows
hello I want to say thank you for the
Lost series thank you
[Music]
uh even for commercial use um uh what do
you mean the uh free binaries or
whatever
um yeah I think so we basically want to
kind of like be like go dots licensing
model I guess but the source code is
behind patreon
so not quite like Godot
and we're also not really trying to
compete with Godot because they're like
well I had because the thing is like I
want to make yeah like sure I want to
make a game engine but I also want to
make games
like I want to make games I want to make
games and Chip games and so that's the
other thing like if we can just make
games and sell them on Steam and make a
lot of money that way then also like
hazel the the prize of Hazel doesn't
really matter as much but obviously
right now we're developing the engine we
have no games to sell
then it's important yeah
do it like unreal and take five percent
royalty when Title earns over one
million dollars ah I don't think we'll
do that
that's kind of hard to enforce and
probably requires lawyers and stuff I
don't want to deal with that I'd rather
write code and make games
[Music]
plus playing
is it really worth it to support
multiple graphics apis with interfaces
uh if you want to ship on different
platforms then yes
it's kind of necessary
hey Turner do you know something about
unigen have you ever used it I haven't
used it I've seen a lot about it I think
it's more for like
non-game related commercial purposes
like simulation and visualization and
stuff
um but it does look pretty cool
thank you chat for entertaining me this
evening I'm probably gonna go now
how does Hazel currently work this was a
while ago how does Hazel currently work
when migrating an old project to the
latest version of Hazel is that an issue
is that an issue that isn't unreal we
like to support backwards compatibility
meaning like when it reads an old file
when you save it it will update it
obviously but when you read it in it
will like the the deserializer still
will support the old way of doing things
usually
so we try not to break it
um
but I think I think some things are kind
of broken because they have to be but
yeah
why volcanal DirectX I explained that
earlier basically because platforms more
platforms
and where you don't like plan on
shipping on Xbox anytime soon
what's the least fun you've had recently
while writing software I find that I can
very often encounter an issue that
completely kills my motivation well the
first thing that came to mind was when
we wrote the GitHub patreon thing so for
those of you who don't know
um once you do sign up
on patreon.com
and you want your Hazel access you go to
git.hazalengine.com
and you can basically connect your like
because it's handled automatically now
it used to be you had to send me a uh
um a private message on patreon that was
like super annoying and
uh people were annoyed they have to had
to wait like a week to get access so we
made this thing
um
get.hazalengine.com and basically what
you do is you connect your patreon
account you connect your GitHub account
and if this stuff is like you know it
will obviously validate that your
patreon of the right tier and whatever
and then if everything goes well then
you'll get an invitation emailed to you
from GitHub
um
and so this beautiful thing is written
with node.js
um and obviously with the patreon and
the GitHub apis uh so
I did I think I did the bulk of that
probably and Peter did a lot of work on
it as well
um so basically for a month back in like
October last year October November last
year Peter and I became web devs
and that was a dark time
like that was uh there were like it
wasn't all bad
but like I don't know man like game
engine developer becoming a web dev like
that's a dark path I think no offense to
web Developers
but
[Music]
yeah
enough said
music playlist plays epidemic sound Jazz
that's it you can probably find it on
Spotify
how'd you go about learning Vulcan did
you just read the dogs that you learn
some when you were at ea uh mostly EA
and then Sasha worms examples and stuff
and obviously referring to the spec
slash
probably some other websites grueling
stuff
what do you use for audio playing
um we use mini audio
Library called mini audio
and a lot of
caught on top of that
was able to standard is using Hazel we
use table for 7 17 at the moment uh we
don't use modules and yes we will
upgrade to 20 soon
I was supposed to do that I think but
someone I think Jay did that a while ago
um right
one senior web dev is crying from this
now it's me sorry Anton
um
but uh yeah I mean it's just not like my
piece of cake but it's also kind of like
it's difficult like when you just really
need to use node.js for something for
example
uh and you're just not like you don't do
it for a living so therefore you're
obviously not as experienced any good
with it it's very easy to get frustrated
kind of like you know if I asked you
presumably I don't know what your Balkan
experience is like but if I asked you to
quickly do something in Vulcan you'd
probably be pulling your hair out not
because it's necessarily bad but just
because you're obviously not in your
elements and you're also not going to
use it long enough to commit learning a
lot of it so therefore yeah
if yarn hasn't answered your question
yet he either hasn't seen it or he's
busy answering other questions what's
that in reference to Peter well he
doesn't feel like answering it yes that
I don't know what you're talking about
there now he sees your question in chat
I think he has his reasons
what are you guys talking about
why Shadow ban me Channel
do I have to answer a tough question now
because I actually don't know what you
guys are referring to
let me scroll up
[Music]
I actually can't see
what do I think about web GPU or wasm
haven't really used it too much
oh here we go here was your question Mr
ago so what is your opinion on new
systems programming languages like Zig
and rust rust is funny because you guys
hear what happened with rust in their
whole trademark situation I just heard
about that today what the heck foreign
[Music]
at the moment
um Zig uh I haven't really looked into
[Music]
but I I don't know I don't really have
an opinion well actually my stock
standard answer for that is basically
like
I don't care and the thing is like
yes I may be a programmer but I'm not
like what I call a meta programmer
meaning I don't really care about
programming I
I obviously like programming but I like
it because it lets me create things like
an artist yeah like I'm not like you you
can't say a painter is like fanatical
about paint brushes and pants and stuff
of course there are people like that but
most of them probably like it because it
lets them draw things let them create
art like it let it's a tool that lets
you do what you it lets you express
yourself and create what you want and
what's in your head and put it down on
like on a canvas
right and so in that kind of fashion
C plus is a tool there's a language that
I use for me not because I love C plus
which I do but not because I love C plus
plus but I like it because it lets me
create games and do stuff like hazel
right and it gives me enough like
control where I can actually achieve the
things that I want and like if I want to
make the computer do this and I want to
I know that like CPUs are good at doing
this specific thing and this needs to be
the case and that needs to be the case
and the hardware needs this and that C
plus plus gives me the tools to make
that happen
and so if I have a design for a
particular like way I want to do things
or a particular way I want to lay out
data or a particular algorithm or
whatever in my head I can express I can
put that down onto a canvas using C plus
right so therefore I like C plus because
it lets me do what I want to do but I
don't really care that it's c plus that
lets me do that and I'm definitely not
if C plus already does that for me I'm
very unlikely
to start looking into other things like
rust and Zig and whatever else because
why
because the limit to my expression is
not the tool I'm using it's not C plus
table plus is not limiting me in any way
and like again that's not to say that
it's the best language available and
that my life wouldn't be easier or maybe
more bug free if I had used something
with like more pedantic ownership
semantics or whatever like rust
yeah I'm not saying that I'm just saying
that the language I use
is like the least of my concern at the
moment because I like it's doing what I
needed to do and that's that
so that is my that's probably a good
place to end it that is my uh this could
be an episode of the channel podcast
which by the way I haven't done in a
while yeah
um
but yeah
ah
[Music]
does Hazel use quaternions or Euler
angles
um
internally uses quaternions but we
obviously don't make people write out
quaternions by hand like we use oil
angles for like displaying
the rotations and stuff but internally
is quaternions and the animation system
is quintonians
kind of has to
turn around is good
a few turnarounds
is the channel podcast actually thing
yeah I did like two episodes
I would do more but like I I'm just not
a very like Community oriented person
like I don't really know many people
from the community and like therefore I
don't really have guests like if someone
like wants to go on the channel podcast
and they're an interesting person like
hit me up business at thechannel.com
send me an email
I don't know tweet at me like whatever
like just
you know we could sit down and do a
podcast if you are like worthy meaning
like if talking to you would provide
good content
um but like because I love I don't know
I like Puck I love talking to people
like I'm a pretty social person so like
I definitely enjoy making podcasts but
it's just like I don't really know that
many people and
um you know to go ahead and start
finding like guests for the podcast what
I should be working on Hazel and also
making YouTube videos which I'm behind
on like
but that's all if basically what I kind
of need to do probably
uh is
um
[Music]
I should get like I should get like a
manager
or someone to to find me guess and then
that way they could be like all right
today you're doing you're you're
interviewing this guy or like you're
doing a podcast with this guy and then
that way I could just sit down and do it
would you have John Carmack on the
podcast of course I would
invite Beyond
yeah that'd be fun do a podcast with
Peter
yeah actually I am heading to Sweden
uh
uh well I haven't officially got the
fights yet but I'm going to euroblade
this year and I plan to pop into Sweden
um and so I am going to hang out with
Peter a bit so maybe actually we can do
an IRL podcast that would be kind of fun
then I'll have to like bring my mic and
stuff
and the holiday is going to become a
business trip maybe good maybe we can
expense that
we'll see
[Music]
but yeah if you guys want to see someone
on the podcast
then just like
just let me know and just like tweet at
them and be like hey will you go on the
channel podcast and I guarantee to you
that if you guys get someone who would
make a good guest
and they say yes
and that way I don't have to like
spend time setting this up basically if
you do the work for me then I guarantee
to you I will sit down and make a
podcast with them okay that is my
promise to you
so just make that happen
all right
I want to see Andrew Tate on the podcast
that's hilarious
I actually asked I actually asked
Sebastian and he said no because well he
said not at this time or whatever
because he's not really into that kind
of stuff
but yes I I wanted to do one with him
have Joe Rogan on that's funny
all of these people I would do by the
way all of these people I would have a
podcast with
so yeah set it up guys do it stream do
it I dare you set it up and I'll do a
podcast even before let them dare I'm
that suicidal hopefully that doesn't
trigger anything but
it's like YouTube channel terminated
China got rejected yep I even the even I
got rejected do you but can you believe
it even me
that's fan on Everyone likes being on
stage yeah I get that
[Music]
Dev doc yeah I know devdawg talk to him
either
sorry guys
that uh I don't know why my OBS does
that it's just like basically what
happens maybe you guys can help me with
this issue am I live again I should be
live again
um but basically what happens that's
happened before when I was like testing
it out nothing like everything was fine
obviously just stream for like three
hours straight zero dropped frames and
then all of a sudden it goes red and it
drops every single frame like due to
network every single frame and obviously
I can still see chat my internet's still
working fine and then and then I have to
close OBS reboot it and then start the
stream again so I don't know why that's
going to be annoying though if that
happens let them dare and stuff
hello YouTube Works fast determinating
his channel that's funny
how did you learn to utilize a Shader
pack I have Googled it and can't find
anything about them other than Minecraft
well our Shader pack is kind of a Shader
pack and Hazel are just something I kind
of made up to solve a problem so
that's how I learned it I just I created
it
that's the best way to go right if you
just create things then you can't really
be wrong
um because you're it's kind of like your
design you know what I mean like you
can't like be like I don't know how to
do this because you're the one who made
it so you can just keep making stuff and
even if it's trash it's yours so that's
how I roll
um all right guys uh seriously though
it's getting late and uh I for the last
two days I've gone to bed at like 2 A.M
um and I've been feeling like crap for
the last few days so I want to go to bed
early today and it's already 10 o'clock
and I'm panicking but yeah
do you like a Japanese cartoon Cherno
um I do like uh I do like the occasional
like Studio Ghibli movie
I do quite a lot
um
and I do like Japan a lot because we my
wife and I went there on our honeymoon
and it was like the best and I love it
so I really want to go to Japan again
probably next year
all right guys thank you for watching
hope you enjoyed the live stream don't
forget next weekend let him dare I'll be
streaming like the three days
I'll be sleeping as well I won't be
streaming that but three days of content
and three days of Hardcore hazeling and
making a game in Hazel with Tim and
Peter
um this is very exciting stuff uh and I
hope you guys will be around for that
I'll probably stream before that as well
in fact I did have the idea next Tuesday
so in a week from now same time I did
have the idea to basically quickly slap
in and undo reduce system into Hazel in
that live stream but we'll see because I
have to iron out all the render issues
before then have a few videos to make as
well busy week
um
so we'll see
but yeah thank you guys for watching
and I will see you next time goodbye
[Music]